through a heavy-metal door was shown
what is a warehouse of human suffering
thousands of mainly sub-saharan Africans
are incarcerated in Libya's system of
makeshift detention centers and the
state of them is shocking this is lunch
it's spoons first then hands to wipe up
the last smears of food
this is an absolutely depressing sight
it's suffocatingly hot it smells there's
not enough room for people to lie down
everybody we've spoken to says that
they're not getting enough to eat
there's no clean water and there's one
more than 200 people in here and between
them they're having to share just one
bathroom put your hands up you wanted to
go to Europe
most people here were arrested whilst
trying to cross the Mediterranean
Europe is pressuring Libya a country
wrecked by civil war to act as policemen
for its migrant crisis but for those
locked up there is only despair people
filing over every day because of hunger
you know we see brothers falling falling
down we can even help them everyday
things get away we don't want to stay
with these people these people like
animals we are not limited we tenacity
we didn't kill anyone we didn't take
money for someone we didn't do any crime
it is a brutal place to end up these
Nigerian women who were kept in a
separate area claimed they were beaten
when they tried to escape they begged
for help
ostrich a badly treated badly what
happened to you what did they do me not
only me the men who run the centre
demand we stop filming
accusing the women of lying to make them
look bad it's impossible to verify what
we're told
but it is clear the Libyan authorities
are overwhelming
you knows Muslims and hygiene problems
many people in one place it's a very
difficult area to say frankly we need
more and more that's what it what I can
tell you I need more help from you yeah
Libya has become the Gateway to Europe
from Africa the instability caused by
the Revolution which saw Gadhafi sweats
from power has made these shores a
Smuggler's paradise the lack of security
means hundreds of thousands of migrants
are now entering the country hoping to
reach Europe on flimsy boats but many
don't make it the bodies of these people
were recovered from the sea last month
most of the Mike on roots from
sub-saharan Africa passed through
Tripoli triggering many stay in this
area often more than ten to a room
whilst they work to pay the smugglers
the mayor's neighborhood so he's
organizing but as illegal migrants they
face many dangers tell me about the what
difficulties did you find on the way
this man tells me he was held in a
detention center for months until his
family paid off the guards
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one place people do feel safe is this
church where the pastor's through song
and sermon one of the dangers of
traveling illegally to Europe outside
amongst the congregation we meets
lorentz she tells me how she started her
journey in Nigeria but was forced into
sexual slavery by the smuggling gangs he
managed to escape me I'm pregnant with
them but I have the photo pending you're
pregnant
yes with who's the father
some somebody who raped you
so what would you do
I'll show my country so God for to in my
life you know what to stay down for
those who are courts they wait in limbo
with no legal rights and not much chance
of consular access it can take months or
even years of living in this squalid
hell before they're deported
Alex Rossi Sky News Libya